et maintenant nous passons un autre tété
ou de la semaine
[Musique]
les jours
car morgane là monsieur
morgan la seule actrice qui avoue
qu'elle a couché pour réussir d'une
façon tout est filmé donc alors tu étais
ou parce que effectivement vous étiez en
train de préparer votre cabaret
itinérant donc on va en parler la f10 je
sens un peu moins concentré que celui ci
rien de ce qui est humain ne m'est
étranger se traite une vieille formule
pourrait jouer
quand tu fais un 69 s'appelle cros quoi
on a perdu j'ai
alors que d'habitude et 23 ans portant
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr il revient à morgane je me
souviens quand on vous a vu arriver
petit provincial en train de devenir une
star du x j avais pas qu'il y avait eu
des sites pornos connaît maintenant avec
des catégories vous auriez été dans la
catégorie accent du sud
regarde
là pourquoi c'est devenu une star aussi
vite parce que vous n'êtes pas les les
sourcils trop maquillée et pas les seins
refaits c'est ça je pense que on se
faisait une serre on se fait une
certaine image de la pornostar quand on
dit et moi j'ai gardé mon image et ça
étonne pas mal de banal de pas mal de
monde donc c'est peut-être une raison et
correspondait à ce que les gens
attendent et peut-être non une peu femme
enfant peut-être une personne qu'on peut
croiser dans la rue qui peut être
n'importe qui pas forcément quelqu'un
destiné pour ça qui a travaillé pendant
des années j'arrive j'essaie d'être
naturel j'aime pas mon image et sa
valeur de marché
du net
et voir alors vous étiez rebelles vous
aviez envie d'emmerder le monde à
commencer par vos parents et aujourd'hui
vous dites j'ai la vie dont je rêvais
vous avez déclaré je suis peut-être une
femme objet mais je vais totalement
décidé oui
quand je me revois s'était pas qu'on a
dans sa main j'ai l'impression d'avoir
une petite fille qui a juste envie de
liberté
j'étais avec mon mec en fait rire
santoro exactement il est décédé depuis
et en fait j'avais juste envie de vivre
une vie extraordinaire pas comme les
autres n'en faire qu'à ma tête de
bouleverser tous les codes c'est vrai
que je suis issu d'une famille un peu
simple de coiffeur un peu rigoriste gène
war espagnol oui c'est ça on n'avait
rien vu du monde c'était une bulle trou
aseptisé pour moi et tout à coup je me
suis rendu compte de la grandeur du
monde 2010
et non je me suis ouvert qu'à mon petit
ami malgré tout ce qu'on peut penser de
moi parce que je laisse aussi parler
parce que parfois ça sert à rien de tout
le temps rebondir et je le fais cette
fois oui j'ai fait cinq six films avec
mon petit ami et je ne regrette rien
parce que j'ai une vie extraordinaire
aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré mon mari dans
la musique j'ai une petite fille d'un an
et j'ai une vie d'artiste je suis sur
les scènes j'ai fait des albums je
m'éclate j'ai pas spécialement de deux
revanches à apprendre je trouve que tu
ne vieillit pas si je vais non elle est
toujours aussi belle qui a 20 ans
y a un truc avec 1
il faut arrêter vous excuser d'avoir
fait six ou sept films pose c'est
vraiment pas grave non j'ai pas arrêté
d'être très bien bon je m'excuse pas
mais je n'ai pas simplement j'ai juste
pas envie d'être cette blonde toute sa
vie qui n'a fait que ça c'est vrai que
quand rocco débarque sur un plateau
c'est un dieu que le phallus
flamboyant comme dirait holy dis est une
fille qui arrive sur un plateau avec une
image un peu sexy c'est une [ __ ] et je
n'ai jamais été bah voilà et si votre
fille voulait avoir la même vie que vous
je ferai tout pour qu'elle ne l'est pas
parce que si j'ai fait ça c'est parce
que je n'ai vu en fait j'ai vu que cette
solution pour me libérer pour
monter à paris goûter à paris j'ai envie
d'offrir à ma fille tout les toutes les
armes j'ai envie qu'elle voyage j'ai
envie qu'elle voit le monde et qu'elle
comprenne toutes les possibilités qui
s'offrent à eux
est-ce que votre fille vous lui direz
que vous avez fait un un bêtisier sur
nrj 12 avec matthieu delormeau
alors je pense que c'est la seule chose
que je n'assume pas
bon voilà alors quand je dis tu t'étais
où comme ça c'est qu'en fait vous
occupiez de votre cabaret itinérant
le cabaret de clara morgane
alors vous mettez en scène donc des
humoristes des magiciens des danseurs
des chanteurs des acrobates des artistes
burlesques voit la boule verte voilà je
vous ai créé ça et vous allez faire une
tournée dans toute la france ça commence
dans les hautes france le 27 et 28
janvier et ensuite il ya tout un tas de
deux dates on appelait hier par exemple
si je peux le dire toutes les dates sont
disponibles à la billetterie est ouverte
mais les gars sont disponibles sur clara
morgane point com et alors on va écouter
un échantillon
[Musique]
ça vous va
ok
[Musique]
i'm so excited des pointer sisters
repris notamment gagnent
ils avanceraient du cabaret c'est vrai
et tous les artistes articule auto et
puis tous les ans il ya le calendrier
car marianne
chaud mégots et compagnie c'est la
quinzième édition c'est un classique
cent mille exemplaires c'est devenu un
rendez vous artistique pour moi et ça me
plaît toujours beaucoup de l'or et clara
pour ce calendrier comme il faut donner
c'est comme le facteur on donne ce qu'on
veut non
alors le pit cette année donc vous
partez à la campagne avec deux mètres
donc voilà
c'est plus polémiques c'est que voulait
initier votre soeur au plaisir du
voyeurisme mais c'est votre vraie petite
soeur oui c'est vrai que toutes les
soeurs ont dîné ensemble complètement
nue
il manque un sergent
mais c'est comme le cigare franchement
qu'ils aimeraient autre chose qu un
cigare dans cette vitrine donne
peut-être effectivement c'est une
métaphore de l'initiation
comme vous pouvez le remarquer ma soeur
est extrêmement timide votre soeur
timide oui elle est extrêmement six mois
bien mais elle l'a fait pour me faire
plaisir évidemment enora malagré n'a pas
aimé là dedans elle a trouvé ça cool moi
j'attaque cqgl sécu tout ça
enora malagré éteint et en cas pour moi
parce que jamais vu quelqu'un autant
changer de d'attitude en principal dit
du mal de quelqu'un suite à lui saute
dans les bras ensuite elle dit qu'elle
ne connaît pas est bipolaire vraiment
beaucoup de problèmes et je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas sûr de soi
qui est profondément jalouse de toutes
les femmes
l'essence de la féminité elle est
magnifique et jaloux deux personnes elle
ne l'est pas si parce que elle est
absolument pour moi jalouse des femmes
parce qu'elles se dispute avec elle bon
toi tu es fan de nabila donc on a
compris à peu près le niveau donc
[Applaudissements]
price vient là gentiment je rigole
c'était une blague je vois votre
scénario de merde dans votre calendrier
se dit rien mais là je suis là qu'on
voit là non parce que quand on lit
content mais je vois le déroulement du
scénario est maintenant tu n'as que vous
allez chez j'ai eu un piège et j'ai rien
dit c'est rien dit on va commencer une
polémique là-dessus en bas non moi j'en
veux pas boire je ne dis pas que ton
livre et de la mer parce que je n'ai pas
encore lu choisir moi je lirai votre
calendrier bravo
[Applaudissements]
parler au coeur
à quand donc le calendrier on en a parlé
de lingerie la lingerie clara morgane
les accessoires qu'un mangane oui les
tétines premier rang non c'est nous j'ai
une ligne de sony style vous voulez tout
je suis une entrepreneuse rêveuse qui
est une artiste au fond donc j'explore
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux